hello everyone today i'm not going to
talk about any biological concept today
i'm online to share a happy moment with
you guys
we have crossed 100 000 subscriber in
this channel and that's a huge
thing for me and this is possible
because of you guys without your
constant support it was not possible
this journey was not possible today i
just received the silver play button
from the youtube and that's why i wanted
to share this happy moment with all of
you guys so let's celebrate together
[Music]
[Music]
thank you youtube for this awesome award
and this is only possible because of you
guys without you i'm nothing the channel
is nothing so keep on subscribing my
channel and share the link with your
friends
so let me share some interesting facts
about this channel you guys are watching
my videos for 5 million minutes that's a
huge motivation for me to make more
videos like this
anyway my videos are not only watched in
india but also my viewers are from all
across the world top geographies include
india usa uk australia and philippines
that's amazing
majority of you guys have commented and
shown your love in my videos and that
what motivates me to make such videos
but i also take the haters comment
really seriously i try to learn from my
mistakes i try to
take that feedback and improve my
content so please let me know your
experience with my channel in the
comment section don't forget to put it
in the comment do you want to know about
my struggle my journey so far in youtube
then let me know in the comments i will
make a detailed video about that but by
the way guys i'm also present in other
social media like instagram facebook all
the links are provided in the
description you can follow me there feel
free to connect i would be really happy
to help anyway share this video with
your friends share my channel link with
your friends such that i can reach big
audience and thanks for your constant
support see you in next video